yo Bole C podcast man special guests in
here two of them my guy go toes hey hey
what's happening what's happening Mr
Little One AKA Uno yo yo yo yo glad to
be here we got the Bay in San Diego in
the building right now yeah what's going
on first of all why y'all say that again
one more time the Bay in San Diego yeah
the West Coast baby yeah what brings you
guys here to together um we got a few
things man uh he had just wrote a
song that I uh that he wrote for him we
didn't write you know he wrote a song
for me I said man I want to I want to do
something different and he had a track
man and I was like man I'm feeling that
one let me get on that and uh he blessed
me with the writing and uh I got up on
there and it came out really good so
it's a new song called wake up actually
we're going to be at K day today we're
going to feature the song Wait so you're
rapping yeah yeah I'm rapping on there
how long have been rapping don't to been
R yeah well you know I don't oh I saw
old school like album cover of yours
right yeah yeah yeah that so this is so
this is not new to you n nah nah it
ain't new to me but but but what I say I
don't consider myself a rapper I'm a
reciter man I'm I have fun because
people got to write the raps for me so I
just take the words you know and and do
what I do have some fun with it that's
what music is about CU you if you put
album out back in the day right yeah the
Gold Rush how long ago was that uh sh
about 15 years ago [__] yeah I think
people see you as like an executive OG
and when I when I did black and brown
entertainment I was I was an executive
for the first you know almost 10 years
of it before I even hit the mic the
first song I did would ever was the walk
on toes with South Park Mexican and that
that hook he did he wrote the hook that
that thing was all over the radio he's
uh definitely in the headlines a lot
even though despite being in jail yeah
he going to stay in the headlines what
is your take on kind of like that whole
situation there's it seems as if people
have like a hard Line in the Sand in the
Lettin hip-hop Community where they're
either like you know [__] [__] him if
you're associated with him I don't know
like it just feels like I don't I don't
know I'm not fully educated on what
happened with him I just know he got
convicted you know right but what is
your thought process on on controversy
currently I mean he's just when like I
always say when he gets out he's just
going to have to speak on it and you
know that's really all I got to say when
he gets out he's going to he's going to
get so much shows you would think N I
don't know man I don't know I mean I
don't know cuz you're going to have uh
you know it ain't going to just happen
like that they're going to have
stipulations I'm sure
you know what I mean especially with
that those type of charges that's fair
you know um what about you man what's
going on with with Uno well like he said
uh you know the Cho Music Festival is
everything to me but beyond the artist
standpoint it's just connecting the dots
and the culture and that's kind of how
me and goto just kind of came together
symmetrically and just organically you
know what I'm saying besides the music
so when we did that song we started
sharing more music we we spent more time
together and I ended up doing a a two
album deal yeah I let me say something I
really like uh I didn't when I started
really getting into his music I he
started sending me all these songs for
me you know and I started bumping I'm
like I started going into I'm like man
oh man he gets down you know and I and I
like the odies and he he was flipping
them tight I'm like oh he got something
you know what I'm saying and I was I
don't know did you think I was going to
be able to flip that song when I did it
yeah so so when he's like yo let's do
this song like you you heard goto goto
got natur natural right natural spit
natural flow you know so when when he
asked me I'm like absolutely you could
do that then you know we got the lyrics
out there and then one day he just hit
me and the song was done wow I got it
done quick too like in a couple hours
you know for people who don't know Uno
you're kind of like um you're like one
of the ogs in the Cho rap world the
pioner how long have you been at this
cuz well well my first album once in a
decade came out in
1996 [__] you know 96 and then and I was
nine I got to you know what's crazy I
had a 9-year-old the other day uh when I
was in Reno and he was saying now this
could have been what homicide or maybe
this could have been suicide from Once
in a decade and he's nine and he's nine
that's crazy right but I mean you know
I've always I've always felt that you
know the whole Cho rap thing that's cool
but I never really seen it that way I've
always seen music like he was saying
like art like no no color no age No No
Label I've I've always looked at music
like freedom and that and and and so has
Goos and I think that's what's been able
to to align us you know not necessarily
thinking in in a box when it comes to
your crowd your audience yeah yeah like
you know we for the culture and
everything but ultimately man like the
magnitude of what we're doing is freedom
yeah I always tell tell people like I
think um you know growing up cuz I'm
from Phoenix right so we had MC Magic
and MB Riders and nasty boy click before
they MB Riders and all that but like I
listen to uh what was Kool-Aid show
pocco SP Loos [__] I used to be the
board op and all that [__] I used to go
to all the low rider shows so I was like
very hip to the culture but the music
necessarily didn't ever really like a
lot of the Cho rap [__] was like very
hey this is for us yeah you saying yeah
yeah and and don't get me wrong and and
it is but I mean that doesn't like there
is more than than samp more yeah there's
more than just sampling a song and
rapping there [__] that I was like a fan
of too like you everybody expects it to
sound like Simon right when there really
is like skeletons being made out of
these Melodies remedies made make
memories you know what I'm saying yeah
and then like I think some of the high
power guys are dropping [__] with like
Busy Bone like and and some of but
there's real MC's too like Shadow and MC
Kos and MC you know there's real MC's
too I always felt that we were so much
more you know what saying I think bash
did a good job of breaking that door
down to be like hey I happen to be Latin
but I'm making party music that if you
live in New York Florida you still bang
it out right you can still bang it out
and it's it's still the same thing
synonymously with the festival like you
know the festival consists of all the
cultural elements but it's just a door
for everyone to come through and
experience the culture for sure you know
what I'm saying that's happening
in onco Deo on CCO de Mayo in San Diego
it's going to be crazy yeah the Legacy
the midnighter slle and the wicked Del
phonic Jrock
Shad going to be crazy coyote yeah
they're dope go toes I'm going be up in
the house you know go toes coming
through we got man we got a whole bunch
of stuff lined up like I said man you
know got a whole layout man yeah we got
a whole layout you know I signed a two
album deal with him the English album
will be El Cho and the Spanish album is
El Mexicano and you know and then we got
a joint project that we working on
together as well oh that would be hard
so you know we got a lot of music we got
a lot of visual we got a lot of shows we
got a lot of a lot coming to I want to
give you props because I feel like
you've been very instrum instrument in
terms of
uh Bridging the Gap
between Southern California and Northern
California Latinos M yeah you know we
just communicating with each other uh a
lot more conversations are happening uh
naturally you know what I'm saying uh uh
you know and more to come um you know
it's it's going to take some time but
you know you know it's good to
communicate and and get on to another uh
you know far future I was going to say
do you think like in terms of like where
that like just kind of the relationships
of like certain artists with certain
artists from from up North the down
south or even guys like like you like
who you've worked with like like 10
years ago would any of that stuff have
been possible five years ago CU it feels
like there's been a lot more putting
some of the politics [__] to the side
and just kind of uniting on on yeah I
mean no it wouldn't have been possible I
mean could have been but I mean it would
have just been a lot more uh it would it
would have been a lot more I would say
um more complicated and difficult I
think through the times now and what's
going on uh uh in the last few years
within the prison system I believe has
helped out um things to help develop
things in the streets and um you know
there's a lot of Latins that are not
into no type of gangs or no type of
politics that that still feel subject to
uh where they're from yeah just to that
and geographically yeah geographically
and there needs to be some type of now
you know yeah we giving it we're giving
it a chance to we're giving ourselves a
chance to shine a little bit and to work
to work together you know what I'm
saying so you know it's going to take
some time uh you know and it's happening
yeah it's happening right now in your
podcast you know and I and again I think
I think beyond anything I think that the
thing that's important here is not we're
not trying to do anything that's just
transactional we want to do things that
are
transformational you know what I'm
saying and that's the energy that we're
on you know Bes Beyond just music like
you know really building something a
found that comes from a foundation of
Purity M you know like this is this
isn't just about a monetary gain it's
much more than that set an example when
we got together we wer like oh you're
from over here we it it it connected
clicked it right away you know what I'm
saying we got we have and we have a lot
in common so um everything's just coming
in it's coming how it's supposed to be
we coming at it how it's supposed to
come I want to go to go back and give a
shout out to pocos Locos cuz that was a
yeah cuz I mean they put on a lot of
Latino from everywhere I think our tacos
man this guy's hey
bro we're in the middle of the podcast
where you
at the door locked the door is locked a
[__] okay give us the wide angle go my
bad grab take my phone man my bad okay
we're on the wi angle he got us on the
wide angle we can keep he been calling
me and calling I'm like [__]
man okay tell them you're coming